neben mann der dieses amt eher pulsiert
tag und nacht
der hamburger hafen kulturstätte
wirtschaftsmotor und sehnsuchtsort
wir begleiten schweizerinnen und
schweizer die in der metropole am wasser
leben und arbeiten
mal mit den strom mal gegen den wind sie
alle sind an die elbe gekommen um hier
ihr glück zu finden
der hafen ist für sie weit mehr als ein
arbeitsplatz er ist abenteuer heimat und
hoffnung auf ein anderes leben dort oben
im norden hier im dorf wie die ottenser
ihren stadtteil liebevoll nennen ist
saralisa zu hause erst gestern abend ist
aus den ferien zurückgekommen
mit ehemann frank war sie vier wochen
mit dem bulli ihrem vw bus unterwegs
sind also ein wunderschöner
sonnenuntergang sie so richtig richtig
wieder schaftlich für roh- und eine
hahne für big fahrer das herz macht
einfach so kurzen speziell selbst stets
irgendwie nach so nach so langen reise
und in zürich und so ich trotzdem so
darf also ganz kurze ganz gut für herz
und setzen
quer durch europa ging die reise nach
portugal auf die azoren und in ihre
heimat die schweiz noch sind sarah lisa
und frank voller eindrücke von den
ferien vor das konto des formulars ist
die auswahl mit dem bulli unterwegs zu
sein ist für sarah lisa immer eine gute
gelegenheit um über neue ideen
nachzudenken und auch darüber wie es
beruflich weitergehen soll
für mich dass ich eigentlich mit schafe
und mehrere auftrag irgendwie eine
sinfonie thema anbieter und wenn die
geschichte selber suchen und auch viel
zu investieren und dass das selbständige
dran das ist für mich eine faszinierte
heimatort in der redaktion und einfach
so gemerkt na ja ich wollte eigentlich
dass jeder engagiert
außergewöhnliche tage sind an diesem
wochenende angesagt die hamburger feiern
ihren haaren geburtstag
auch sarah lisa zieht es hinunter an die
elbe mit dem schiff fährt sie von
ottensen an die landungsbrücken
das wetter ist norddeutsch nass so wie
es am polarkreis 100 bezeichnungen für
schnee geben soll
so haben die hamburger zig ausdrucke für
den regen
[Musik]
als erstes zieht es sie zu ihrem
arbeitsplatz im hafen richtung heede dem
partyschiff an brücke 10
bella
für das wieder gab es bereits ist kaputt
nein nein
die heizung ist kaputt oder was
[Musik]
sie ist schön sie sind möglich
rund eine million zuschauer lockte
hafengeburtstag in die metropole an der
elbe feste tradition am eröffnungstag
ist die einlaufparade
ein paar hundert meter vom wasser
entfernt die zweite heimat
[Musik]
es laufen die vorbereitungen für das
stück ganz hamburg feiert
hafengeburtstag
und was macht thomas ich spiele heute
also jetzt die samen stehen natürlich
und amazon die messwarte gute stücke mit
immer gern nach ökologisch fuß auf der
hand man sowas der schöne abschluss vom
wochenende die zweite heimat ist heute
station eines kulinarischen
stadtrundgangs die einzige werbemaßnahme
die sich thomas und andreas leisten dass
er ist mein stichwort aber für montag
bei dem schönen kalten wetter kriegen
sie heute dafür einen schönen selber
gemachtes eis
das ist ein schokoladeneis da ist
vanille mit wohn ein bisschen
passionsfrucht und probieren sie mal
schokoladensauce man kann einmal so
rüber wenn er sie gern fluter wählen
großen theater haben wir wirklich ein
ganz ganz klein und sehr persönlichen
weg gewählt ihre theaterstücke dauernd
also eine stufe eins sehen dann gehen
wir gemeinsam zum essen dann gehen hier
die lichter aus und dann gehen hier die
vorhänge auf
mit der idee von theater und kulinarik
haben thomas sondern erst eine
attraktive nische gefunden
so das heißt illumination alles trug
vater bis zum erstellen
[Musik]
mehr als 300 schiffe tummeln sich beim
hafengeburtstag vor der elbphilharmonie
und verwandeln die landungsbrücken in
ein maritimes spektakel
auf der südseite der lbb hafenmuseum ist
es noch ruhig
ursula riechen berger und ihre
ehrenamtlichen helfer bereiten sich auf
die ankunft der gäste vor
der shooter alles klar sein fest okay
sie vertrauen hat enrico er neu gemacht
dann noch einen schönen arbeitstag
der umgangston ist zuweilen raum
solarien berger hat sich längst daran
gewöhnt seit ihrem neunten lebensjahr
wohnt sie hier ist hat schon eine lange
zeit gebraucht sich das vertrauen zu
erarbeiten als schweizerin im hamburger
hafen da mit den gesetzten hanseaten in
dialog zu kommen
aber wenn man es einmal geschafft hat
dann hat man es auch geschafft sie hat
sich im hafen und bei den alten
seeleuten vor allem durch ihr wissen und
ihre kompetenz einen namen gemacht
hallo hier ist ich sehe ich schon hast
du zwei neue schläuche montiert dann
haben wir ja ist schon die sind tabu
okay das ist noch aus der
entstehungszeit oder das ist von damals
noch von 1909 tatsächlich war könnte ein
bisschen paar tage später sein okay es
ist ja die alte technik und ziehen
wollen haben jetzt gummi die
ehrenamtlichen kommen hierher weil sie
auch davon überzeugt sind dass die
geschichte des hamburger hafens
erzählenswert ist und das tun sie mit
ihrer ganz eigenen art und weise vor dem
erfahrungsschatz aus dem sie schöpfen
können
sie haben als taliban gearbeitet als eva
führer waren zu lande oder zu wasser
beschäftigt und haben so ihre ganz
eigenen blick auf den hamburger haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
giuliano meroni ist doch dem weg zur
arbeit
vor rund zehn jahren zog es den
gebürtigen tessiner in den norden im
hafen steht auf der musicalbühne
sein rat der hauptsitz von entertainment
wieder als die firma ohne schaffe die
ganze büros und einfach so große
tanzsaal wo es stattfindet sein
arbeitsplatz liegt auf der anderen
elbseite giuliano fährt in die tiefe in
den alten elbtunnel der vor mehr als 100
jahren gebaut wurde
es ist schon ianus lieblings arbeitsweg
das ist ja ein vernünftiges daneben
konzentriere of show
meistens so dass die musik und damit
vorbereitet und das jahr über sie lustig
das waren wir da jetzt und wo sind denn
erstmals wieder ein anderer wald und
konnte so sage sage da julian und auf
der anderen die zusage da auch stelle wo
der bühne geht
das theater an der elbe ist eine von
zwei musical bühnen mit exklusiven
standort sechs tage pro woche tritt
giuliano hierauf im stück ich war noch
niemals in new york das theater an der
elbe gibt es seit mehr als drei jahren
von anfang an hat schuljahr noch in der
garderobe hier seinen festen platz
das ist ein schminktisch jetzt dem stück
ohne schauspieler ist letzter film
mitspielen krieger mache ich vielleicht
mal so eine grund das ist einfach pech
gehabt stecken und so und es stinkt
bereich da ist für mich nur in privat
der bereich das heißt dass ich mein
bereich kollege und ich hatte auch mini
mini cooper klamotte da und das baufeld
nicht vom match stück
und das anziehen
das geld nur so ring ein traum bleiben
zur perfekten illusion auf der showbühne
gehören jede menge glitzer und glamour
und zuweilen tiefe einblicke ja das ist
nicht so schlimm seniorenkino schnitt
gemacht
ich gebe aber wir getan stärkung für
einen langen tag legen dvs vor publikum
auf die bühne geht steht das aufwärmen
auf dem programm
das tanzen an sich für mich aber
gewaltig
also ich bin jetzt eine wo sich nicht
gern mit word und muss drückt also berg
her sondern stille mann wir aber eher
schüchtern und eigentlich gar nicht für
die marktbühne über das irgend jemand im
rampenlicht und im mittelpunkt und
später überhaupt nichts aus der
englische ganz komisch tanzen ist julian
aus leidenschaft für den traum daraus
seinen beruf zu machen muss sehr lange
trainieren und die eigene schmerzgrenze
überwinden
mit dem sport angefangen und ich
beteiligt bin und dann habe ich das
jeden tag gemacht bevor es bett gegangen
bin mit der balance bei aus einer klasse
wie hauptstadt und auch bei verstössen
kriegt es ist auf jeden fall wenn das
jeden tag dient damit das auch so bleibt
[Musik]
wenn das schlepperballett auf der elbe
stattfindet gibt es an den
landungsbrücken immer großes gedränge
saralisa es mittendrin
aber schnell wieder schneien
jetzt wankt ein ganz schlepperballett
schlepper sind hier die großen
containerschiffen hoffe ihnen faire und
wie ein wahnsinnig sie bestellen oder so
eine riesige motor und wer dieser wahn
nächste instanz hat er jetzt an gott und
er hat es noch nie und hat jetzt das
jahr otis maxi ist schon mal sehr episch
gerade
[Musik]
für mich sind das so sind die schlepper
so personifiziert sind für mich so die
heimlichen helden vom hoffe dass das
schiff als im märz
[Musik]
das schlepperballett ist traditionell
ein höhepunkt des hafengeburtstages
nicht weit vom spektakel entfernt an der
st michaelis kirche wohnt vorstellung
gott nicht ob er im zweifelsfall für die
jacke mit der sie
[Musik]
der intendant der staatsoper es zu einem
offiziellen empfang eingeladen
auf dem weg dahin tauchte in das bunte
treiben des hafenfestes und die
popkultur der straße ein
[Musik]
was ich noch stressig und so also mich
interessiert eigentlich alles was sie
tue sie sich im moment habe ich sehr
zufrieden
[Musik]
der hafengeburtstag wende für mich jetzt
um hauptstadt sondern etwas dran in der
berner noch das ist eine für mieter die
hafenstraße wurde berühmt durch den
häuserkampf der 80er jahre die gegend um
die einst besetzten häuser ist heute ein
hippes quartier
hier verwandelt sich das hafenfest
innern so kulturelles open air
befreit von touristen gedacht als
alternative gegenbewegung zum
kommerziellen hafengeburtstag
[Musik]
saralisa besuchte ihren mann frank in
der coque wo er als bartender arbeitet
hier haben sich die beiden kennengelernt
[Musik]
heute ist hier alles etwas anders als
sonst
dann hab gar nicht ob mir folgen
ja zigarette automatische romantisch
startete vor amerika von lockt wie war
das nochmal genau das soll denn du hast
gesagt dass wir etwas tätowieren lassen
standard ist voll mit startnummer
knutscht und dana beck käufer noch nicht
in zug zug nach frankfurt dort zum
bremer jetzt zum glück
[Musik]
am hafengeburtstag findet in der coque
die traditionelle klo party statt
eine party aus der not geboren hat fünf
jahre hier gearbeitet so dass es zum
hafengeburtstag sind die klos irgendwann
einfach nur noch dreckig und sie fähig
und keine ahnung also ist nicht schön
auf jeden fall alle sind irgendwie
betrunken und wir müssen irgendwie
jemand hier unterstellen dass ein
bisschen sauber hält und dann war das
irgendwie so ok ja einen jungen
hinstellen wir machen das ja langweilig
ganztag im keller sein und sagte wir
machen zu müssen und das eintrittsgeld
kriegen natürlich die leute die unten
stehen weil das immer noch langweilig
ist haben wir daraus eine party gemacht
man hat sich so in den letzten jahren so
entwickelt und mottopartys daraus machen
nur krieg actos marie antoinette dieses
jahr ist der hades und seine persephone
also die unterwelt
[Musik]
ich meine die haben ja selbst nicht toll
ist das nicht so machst du jetzt
weil auch immer so spannend
[Musik]
schlagermove triathlon g20-treffen
ironman oder alstervergnügen in hamburg
findet fast an jedem wochenende eine
großveranstaltung statt
das kurbelt die wirtschaft an und bringt
menschen unterschiedlicher kulturen an
die elbe da hoffe ich dass man
eigentlich nur ein spaziergang verbindet
fest wir wie extrem unterschiedlich die
kulturen sind und je menschen sind und
das alles macht aber wahrscheinlich auch
zu haben für den intendanten der
staatsoper ist der hafengeburtstag auch
ein arbeitstag
er folgt einer einladung des
geschäftsführers des hamburger
flughafens michael eggenschwiler
ebenfalls ein eidgenosse
ein treffendes hamburger erst ab märz
man kennt sich seit jeher ist der hafen
auch ein ort um geschäfte zu machen
während die hamburger zum 828 wahl den
geburtstag ihres hafens feiern macht
sich thomas gedanken über seine ziele
jetzt im sommer ist dem theater weniger
los als sonst
zeit um über das leben nachzudenken und
natürlich auch über das neue stück vom
etikett mit sich und 50 denn ist
natürlich danke ganz an der spitze
lautet und das ist okay aber gibt es das
zug gekauft kiss kiss castro wie ein
sechser im lotto mit aller macht und
warum sie das alles lebensdaten punkt wo
man unglaublich gutes stück arbeit und
ohne das jetzt sage ich macht stück bis
zur selbsttherapie aber das ist
ehrensache leitthema thomas und andreas
hatten glück und konnten eine wohnung in
hafennähe mieten wenn schon wirklich
ganz genau im blick haben aber es sind
also kreuzfahrtschiff wird es erfahre
und das ist wenn du schreibst imbiss so
ist das immer mit tipi also dass das
hier ist ganz schön was also ist
beschrieb ständiger geschichte präsent
vor die tür geht sozusagen das finde ich
schön auch wenn die queen mary heute
nicht im hafen einläuft
[Musik]
dazu gehört aber das ist jetzt sehr ließ
limits für die drüse genau wo esch und
das ist extrem lud und das ist schon
toll
thomas neues theaterstück spielt auf
einem kreuzfahrtschiff entwickelt das
gemeinsam mit der musikerin eva und zwar
diesmal vor spieler
immerzu die möwen kreischen wirklich
allerliebst von mir schon gefallen
gegen das rauchen du dir alle mühe gibst
du mir gefallen
die sorgen
wir könnten mit mehr speicher sonne
was wir es drehte
[Musik]
mein herz der ohnehin unter wasser
ja aber so ganz glücklich kreiert
zwar ist ein ganz dummes tor da wo sie
so sie jetzt auch gab sachen umsetzen
umso herzlicher extrem arrogant freude
die art und das finde ich sehr schön und
ich glaube es wird etwas ganz
unglaublich emotionales stück des weges
wird das sehr lustigste kulturmacher
sechs theater total schön und so teil
davon aber genau die im moment ganz so
wichtig wie ein bisschen theater auch im
musical theater auf der anderen elbseite
geht es um emotionen
giuliano bereitet sich auf seinen
auftritt vor
in der maske verwandeln stylisten die
darstellerin ihre bühnen charaktere den
letzten schliff bekommt auch giuliano
und für die nächsten stunden seine
jugend zurück
es gibt so steuer das sind so kleine
kunst herrchen also ganz ganz fein und
die stoiber quasi sich hier hinten dann
einfach auf den bereichen fixiert dass
mit haarspray und dass ich dann halt
ganz natürlich aus als hätte ja nur noch
schönes volles haar
[Gelächter]
aber ja ich bin ständig ein letzter
funktionstest vor der aufführung de
zeigen sich die ganz allen außer das ist
jetzt das sogenannte die soundcheck das
heißt die logitech immer großartig sehen
also es geht um das höchste der harmonie
und der level schon gefährdet das heißt
wenn ich auf der bühne bin muss ich raus
und imposante kraft und toben haben zum
beispiel karl schiller 2 mikrofon das
heißt wenn es einen grund also was
kaputt oder irgendwer schweiß tropft
dann wird sofort sondern auch gemacht
oder halt getrennt und dann auf normal
weiter
kurz vor showbeginn schlittschuh lianen
in sein erstes bühnenoutfit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so baut musiker von david villa 54 ad
hoc und das hoffentlich liegt also damit
die dann immer ohne prozent geben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was auf der bühne leicht und beschwingt
aussieht ist in wahrheit eine
körperliche höchstleistung fast drei
stunden im ensemble auf der bühne
giuliano geht bei jedem auftritt an
seine grenzen
eine koalition aber zeitig also sobald
ich auf der bühne bin gott das
spitzenwerk betten schüchtern und das
team verließ mich unser meistens also
ich find's schön warm ich sehe das lied
freut hand dazu lagert und das finde ich
schön dass man energie überbringen
mit dieser tage mit der magischen man
dass die das vermittelt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ganz andere klänge sollen heute im
hafenmuseum zu hören sein
ursula riechen berg erwartet was neues
und lädt zu einem hafen
geburtstagskonzert im schuppen 50 a 1
eine stunde noch dann kommt das
orchester
das so wird der sitzplan ungefähr flöten
sollen erhöht sitzen geigen davor da
hinten kommen die großen brocken und
kontrabässe ich finde es braucht
manchmal war es um die leute hierher zu
locken wir sind auf der südseite der
elbe nicht an der fischbrötchen kulisse
an den landungsbrücken und dann finde
ich kann man gern noch ein zusatz anreiz
bieten sich mit hamburg mit kultur zu
beschäftigen in diesem ambiente und
heute haben wir vor zum ersten mal
klassische musik in diesem raum
erklingen zu lassen
für diese benefizveranstaltung zugunsten
des historischen hafen museums werden
über 70 instrumentalisten ehrenamtlich
musizieren
rund 200 zuhörer sind dem ruf von ursula
reichenberger gefolgt sie hören wollten
von ihm aus der neuen welt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auf sand pauli trifft saralisa ihre
freundin fragen ja
er hat den bord gefunden und wir fragen
dazu als ich mega lustig dass in
portugal so 220 liter bier was man in
deutschland nur 24 von der abfahrt
musste papa welche mitbringen und
freundschaften sind saralisa wichtig
freundschaften die auch tief gehen also
hamburg will ich irgendwie anders energa
freundeskreis haben uns mehr der
grauguss suchen und des weges mit mehr
so lang wie ok die person würde zu
unsozial aufwand und mehr ist dazu das
kann sie sich nicht nach 67 und bisher
immer nur noch besser begründet wurden
die schweizer verfassung gar dass mir zu
hoch und verzogen
vom ersten moment webserver mutter
verliebt
alles was nicht
wir beschlossen den ethik in mir
bearbeiteten magath warnt sie das
netteste bleiben
[Musik]
ein neuer tag im norden rund 50
kilometer von hamburg entfernt liegt
sehr hoch
in schleswig-holstein dem nördlichsten
bundesland deutschlands
hier lebt giuliano mit seiner familie
und und bebop der liebe wegen zog er
nach itzehoe
seine frau ist hier aufgewachsen
sie wollte wieder in der nähe ihrer
eltern wohnen um sie im alter zu
unterstützen
giuliano ging mit und mit ihm schweizer
traditionen ist nicht so günstig aber
manchmal lust an und mache so ein
aber ich werde immer so zu bekriegen und
der sagt hey mache doch alle immer so am
sonntag soll es morgen kratzten creme
mama kaffee und kakao auf das gemeinsame
frühstück mit frau diane und tochter
leila wird julian in den kommenden
monaten verzichten müssen bei der
familie wird sich einiges ändern
[Musik]
diana ist ebenfalls musicaldarstellerin
ihr neues engagement führt sie
ausgerechnet in die schweiz auf die
seebühne nach thun ins musical cats dass
ich eine ganze zeit lang arbeiten gehe
und nicht zu hause sein wird
und also ich war schon mal ein paar tage
weg aber jetzt ist es eben drei monate
die ich noch tun wir und da die in bei
den thunersee spielen cats spielen werde
worauf ich mich tierisch freut das ist
das erste stück was mich bewegt hat
diesen job zu machen also das war ein
ganz großer antrieb sage ich mal
und so ist es jetzt gerade das wäre
eigentlich mal gerade tauschen jetzt
schon organisieren wie das zu laufen
sagt halabi mitterlehner mit der bibel
und wenn man sich nur was passiert mit
der lehrer weil ich habe kaum geschlafen
und sei man hat wirklich das urteil und
babysitting und ihres große da die oma
und wenn es mal wirklich schlimm
unternehmens abschnitt ist herunter da
machen hat auch maßnahmen und ein rund
zehn metern dann kann es idiotisch
beschäftigen
juliane muss sich neben alltag und
abendlichen bühnenshows zusätzlich auf
ein casting vorbereiten
[Applaus]
die tägliche zugfahrten hamburg nutzt er
zum üben
meistens wird es schon so sagen wir zwei
mal lag seit normale tv und der
rohmaterialien oder gar nicht das ist
das aladin als liiert und es sind vier
wo das singt zweifel der charaktere und
das ist dann so jeder daran die harmonie
data und text und das lied von ihr kann
das heißt wenn ich jetzt mal vorläufig
macht dann ist ich habe das lied aber
klauten immer online musik an damit ich
das mache wie es funktioniert dann heißt
über niederlage
ich weiß dass charlene das casting ist
wichtig julianes derzeitiges engagement
in hamburg neigt sich dem ende zu
was anschließend kommt weiß er noch
nicht und plötzlich ist er wie jetzt
gerade aber so eine völlige umbruch das
ist einfach noch die chance hat das ist
einfach ist das gar nicht und dann
schlussendlich oder man klar machen dass
muslime schafft aber trotzdem muss
natürlich auch geld damit machen
finanzieren
giuliano blickt einer unsicheren zukunft
entgegen
drei tage steht die hansestadt im
zeichen von fernweh reisefieber und
seefahrer romantik
[Musik]
saralisa und ihr ehemann frank genießen
einen freien nachmittag
[Musik]
regelmäßig nehmen sich frank und
saralisa zeit für ihre beziehung und
verbringen ganz bewusst einen tag in der
woche nur zu zweit alles andere
lebensmittel
beide haben sich gegenseitig ihre heimat
gezeigt bevor sie hier in hamburg den
anker geworfen haben
vor seiner dieser umgezogen ist nach
hamburg aus dem kleinen raum tritt durch
die schweiz gemacht
also ich glaube am ende meine produkte
können auch hier bleiben das ging rauf
so eine woche bevor sie ein abschieds
roadtrip der schweiz gemacht und so hoch
wie vor dem krieg zu gewinnen und
ernsthaft zu mega jährigen offenberg das
ist so schön erzählen
das schlank mit zu geben also das
schließt dann nicht wussten die
genannten das was für gründen auch immer
der zweite sex haben sei nicht
vorstellen wie die g20 also dass du
bist du nicht abgeneigt ist das finde
ich eigentlich finde ich einen vorteil
so weit dann stehen uns irgendwie noch
mehr länder hamburg ist ihr zuhause
geworden aber je nach dem nur auf zeit
denn vielleicht lichten sie irgendwann
den anker und ziehen gemeinsam weiter
[Musik]
thomas hat in hamburg festgemacht sein
anker ist lebenspartner andreas auch in
stürmischen zeiten
dieser bildete humor mirlach unglaublich
für sich sodass achtungs macht dann kam
eine native skater heads und betrieb
weniger grund zum lachen und wenn man da
nicht so zusammenhält und besucher
lachen und das ist extrem extremer hitze
und extremer haut zwischen man somit ist
und wo ist sehr zum spaß bringt und auch
ablehnen krieg wenn es mal nicht so gut
geht also darum ganz so zu tage gehört
jetzt zum beispiel moment dass diese mit
sauna genießen das ist toll und das
verbindet die so mehr ist als
landesprojekt irgendwo ne und das ist
schön ein lebensprojekt ein
lebenspartner und ein neuer
freundeskreis
tomas ist in seiner zweiten heimat
angekommen
der hafen ist das tor zur welt doch wer
in hamburg ankommt so heißt es im norden
der habe ein zuhause fürs leben gefunden
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge giuliano geht zum
entscheidenden casting boxenstopp eines
kreuzfahrtriesen eine logistische
herausforderung auch für schweizer crew
mitglieder
saralisa recherchiert für den nächsten
auftrag wie leben und arbeiten die
menschen auf st pauli thomas hat besuch
von seiner mutter und im gepäck eine
überraschung dieses hamburg hamburg